all right we left off at number 11.
let's see this is pretty straightforward
triangle so i can draw it in my messy
style without the line tool
let's see we have a
b
c
this is three
four and six
each angle of triangle abc
has the same measure
as an angle in
triangle x y z which has not been shown
well we should draw that though it has
the same angle i have a
feeling well
this is a similar triangle so x
y
z
x y z
if the length of one side of x y z
is 24
so we just know
some random side here is 24 it could be
this one
maybe i don't know
the length of one side is 24 what is the
possible perimeter of x y z what is one
possible perimeter so here
this is probably this probably has three
correct answers
um which is fun because it in some ways
increases your probability of getting
this right
but when you know that two triangles
have all the same angles you immediately
know that it is a similar triangle which
means that they look the same they're
just of a different scale and if you and
you should watch the similar triangle
video that i made in the geometry
playlist if this makes no sense to you
because this will make no sense if you
haven't heard the term before
but since these are similar triangles
the ratios of the of the corresponding
the sides are going to be the same and
we can you know they're letting us pick
which side is has length 24.
so let's say that the side that
corresponds to side 3 is of length 24
right
we don't know that this is definitely
the case but they're letting us pick so
i'm going to say that you know this side
that x y corresponds to a b so if this
side is 24 then this side is going to be
four thirds
of this side right
you can
hopefully you remember similar triangles
that the ratios of the sides are the
same
so if 3 is to 4 as 24 is 2
well to go from 3 to 24 we multiply by
8. so to go from 4 to this we multiply
by 8.
so 32 and to go from 6 to this we
multiply by 8
48. so this is a possible combination of
sides for a
a similar triangle to triangle abc and
we can just add these up so let's see 24
plus 32
is 56.
56 24 plus 32 is 56 plus 48
6 plus 8 is 14
104. you just bubble type that in 104. i
mean you could have picked the 24 side
is you know this could have been like
this it could have been 24
24 if this is 24 then we're multiplying
by
let me see if this was 24 that means
we're multiplying by 6 to get to 24. so
this would be 18 and this would be 36
and you could add all of those up
together and you would have gotten
another answer and that would have been
correct
and similarly you could have made this
side
you could have made this side 24. if
this side was 24 that means we're
multiplying every side by 4. so this
would have been 12 and this would have
been 16. you could add those up and that
would have been the other the third
possible correct answer for this problem
exciting
let's move on
the sum of five consecutive integers is
a thousand
number 12.
five consecutive integers is a thousand
what is the value of the greatest of
these integers so they're consecutive
integers
so
they're five of them so we could say x
so we want to know the greatest of these
integers so let's say x is the greatest
and so the second greatest is going to
be x minus 1.
the third greatest is x minus 2
the fourth greatest is x minus three and
then the fifth greatest is x minus
four right these are five integers and
they're consecutive and this is the
largest right
and we're going to take the sum of them
so if i take the sum of all of these
numbers and this is a tip if they were
asking for the smallest number i would
have started with x and i would have
gone x plus 1 x plus 2x plus 3 like that
because then x would have been my
smallest number but they said x is the
largest we want to solve for x so the
greatest of these integers so that's why
i subtracted so let's see if we add add
all these up we have five x's so that's
5x
minus 1 minus 2 is minus 3
minus 3 is minus 6 minus 4 is minus 10.
5x minus 10 and they say that the sum is
equals 1000 and this is a output some
fairly simple algebra equation 5x is
equal to
add 10 to both sides
which is also 10 in binary if you are a
geek
and to divide both sides by 5
x is equal to
205 right 200
yes no no no my god i can't divide by 5.
202 right x is equal to 202 202
there you go
not too bad huh all right
number 13.
and i'm going to switch colors because
this pale yellow is getting monotonous
i'll switch to something bold like blood
red no no that's tacky
number 13.
the figure above shows y equals g of x
if the function h is
okay so let me let me draw that because
i don't want to confuse you just saying
a lot of random crap before
uh you see what the graph looks like
although you should have it turned to
the same page
okay so then we draw it like that
i don't have to draw that far down
look something like that
and then it looks something like
this let me draw it in a different color
the line itself looks something
it goes from here goes up like this
then it kind of comes back down like
here
then it kind of bounces and it goes back
up like this
and then they tell us that this line
right here
this is y
is equal to g of
x it's going to be a functions problem i
can tell you already so you should do
the function watch the function videos
or do the function modules on khan
academy so the figure above show the
graph y equals g of x
if the function h is defined by
h of x is
equal to g
of two x
plus two
they wanna know what h of one is equal
to
well with functions you know they're
putting a 1 into this you know black box
so wherever we see the x we put a 1 in
right so h of 1
h of 1
is equal to let's use this to use this
definition g
of two times x well in this case x is
one g of two times one
plus two
so that equals g
of three
plus two and now we have to figure out
what g of 3 is and if you look at this
graph
you know it's
in the book it's more obvious is 1
and then you have a
it pretty much hits 0 right at 3 right
so g of 3 when x is equal to three g of
three is right here that's zero it's
zero g of three is zero
zero so
this is zero so we're just looking for
the two h of one is two that's all
amazing all right next problem
okay
number 14
exactly
four actors four actors
try out for four parts in a play
four parts in a play if each actor can
perform any one of the part
any one part and no one will perform
more than one part how many different
assignments of actors are possible
well let's just say you're just randomly
doing it right so let's let's
put up the actors so
well
so you take the first guy right and you
say well i can put him in any one of
four roles right for the first guy i
could put him in any one of four roles
right
and then the second guy i shouldn't
assume they're all men the second actor
or woman or actress
one role has been taken already right i
mean there are four roles this first
person took it so now there's only three
roles left
right there's three possibilities so
there's one of three possibilities for
that second person correct
okay so the third person how many
possibilities does he or she have left
well two of the roles have been taken
already so there's only two
possibilities for that person and then
the last person to kind of be picked has
only one role left right so the
combinations are literally just four
times three times two times one
so that's that's 12 times 24
combinations
or assignments of
roles and i actually haven't made a
probability in combinations and
permutations video yet i will um and
what once i do watch that if this if
this problem seemed confusing to you but
hopefully it makes a little bit of
intuitive sense i'll see you in the next
video